justin trudeau signale qu'il n'est pas
prêt de quitter son poste de premier
ministre l'accord signé avec le npd
permet aux libéraux de rester au pouvoir
jusqu'en 2025 d'ici là le gouvernement
pourra donc fonctionner dans la
stabilité et la prévisibilité
afin de livrer la marchandise pour les
canadiens en échange de l'appui des néo
démocrates lors des votes de confiance
le gouvernement trudeau s'engage à faire
progresser certaines priorités du npd
entre autres une assurance dentaire pour
les familles moins nanties et un régime
universel d'assurance médicaments dans
les endroits où il ya moins d'alignement
entre le npd et le parti libéral on va
être là pour travailler avec les autres
partis car il ne s'agit pas d'un accord
de coalition aucun élu du npd ne va
faire partie du conseil des ministres le
choix de santé l'aide aux gens une heure
et demie plus tard exactement au même
endroit jack meeting se défend de s'être
agenouillé devant le premier ministre ce
n'est pas de tuer une carte blanche
on restait une parti d'opposition on
garde le pouvoir de se poser le
gouvernement et même de retirer son
appui s'il estime qu'une priorité
commune ne progresse pas suffisamment
mais on commence avec une bon volonté
avec un bon voix fait que on veut que ça
fonctionne
[Musique]
les conservateurs qui ont toujours
reproché à justin trudeau d'être trop à
gauche et trop dépensier tire à boulet
rouge sur le gouvernement libéral
plaindra de passe plus de temps et moins
en moins de respect pour le parlement le
bloc estime que les provinces comme le
québec sont les grandes perdantes de
latence et de piétiner les juridictions
du québec et des provinces en matière de
santé d'assurance ventes d'assurance
médicaments avec la stabilité que
procure cette entente justin trudeau
compte profiter des prochaines années
pour asseoir son héritage et faire
avancer ces grandes aussi et même si cet
accord donne des munitions aux partis
d'opposition en chambre les bloquistes
viennent de perdre levier négociations
important les conservateurs eux une
chance de reprendre le pouvoir à court
terme et si leur ans martin radio canada
ottawa